- Alright, so this is a
crazy story about my dad.
9/11 happened, when I was
a senior in high school,
old boy Catholic high school,
and my mom worked in
the World Trade Center,
so I didn't know what happened to her,
I was worried, you know, was she okay?
I started to cry, hysterical,
because I thought my mother was dead.
This kid, Frank, starts laughing at me,
while I'm crying, about my mother.
So I broke a chair over his head.
That was bad, so my teacher was like,
you're gonna get thrown out of school.
To old boy Catholic high school,
that's a rule, you can't break
chairs over people's heads.
So, I called my dad.
Dad, yeah, I just got
expelled from school,
I broke a chair over some kid's head.
- Alright, I'll be there in ten minutes.
- I was like, you live 45 minutes away,
in Staten Island, there's
no way you're going
to be here in ten minutes.
12 minutes later, somehow,
this guy shows up,
with the New York Yankees batting jacket,
shorts, flip flops,
holding a cup of coffee,
I was like, this is insane.
So he walks into school,
he's like, alright,
I need a meeting with the principal.
- You can't just get a
meeting with the principal.
- He's like...
- Get me a meeting with the principal.
- Two minutes later we're
in the principal's office,
it's me, my dad, Brother Rob.
He says, Brother Rob, what happened?
- Well, your son broke a
chair over someone's head.
- And my dad's like-
- Yeah, but he thought
his mother was dead,
the kid got emotional, there's got
to be something we can do.
- And he goes-
- What part of no don't you understand?
- Come on, there's go to
be something we can do.
We're two grown men.
- Are you some kind of idiot?
- I was like, oh, that was bad,
shouldn't have said that, he goes-
- Chrissy, go stand by the door.
- I was like, what?
- Stand in front of the door!
- Okay.
So my dad says, look-
- I'm going to give you two options.
The second one you're
really not gonna like.
Option one, we figure
out how to get my kid
back in school diplomatically.
Option two, this is going to suck for you,
I come over there and break
both your freakin' kneecaps.
(gasps)
Now, you're going to think
I heard that in a movie,
I'm the guy they write the movie about.
I don't care, I will
call the cops right now
and tell them where I
live, what my birthday is,
social security number.
- He goes, 'cause guess what?
I'd rather go to jail
for the rest of my life,
- Than have you throw
my kid out of school,
and have to listen to his
mother's freakin' mouth!
The choice is yours.
Chrissy, put one minute on the clock.
- What?
- One minute, on the clock, do it!
(clock ticking)
- Okay, so we're going to throw him
off the basketball team,
and he'll have detention
before and after class
the whole school year.
- I'm glad we could see eye to eye.
- Wait, dad, just break his kneecaps,
I don't want to get thrown off the team.
My dad's like shut up,
you almost killed a kid,
you've got to pay.
(cries)
You know, I didn't get expelled though,
and you know, my dad and Brother Rob,
actually became pretty good friends.
I'm pretty sure Brother
Rob works for my dad,
I've seen him making deliveries
at sketchy areas of Brooklyn
that I know my dad frequents,
so yeah, that's my dad, he's a great guy,
and if he kisses you on the cheek,
you're probably getting
whacked, so, sorry.